body cam video shows the moments leading
up to a sheriff's deputy punching a
17-year-old girl during an arrest after
the video captures the teen striking the
officer
first the incident happened on October
22nd after deputies were dispatched to
the Milwaukee County Zoo for reports of
a fight once the deputy arrived to the
scene they spotted no apparent fight
however Zoo security Personnel alerted
the deputy to the four people believed
to be
involved what's up
man fting they're just sitting by theate
and we where are they they're by the
front gate over there yeah the walking
gate we can't really get out cuz they're
just sitting on the gate and they're
arguing with each
other where's the walking gate it's
right there you see where the white car
is look to the left and you'll see like
can you get them on this side or the far
side or what side can you get them from
are offal all what do you mean can I
talk to them from can I get them from
here or do I have to exit the park to go
over there oh no you can go through the
parking lot and the gate is right there
it's like at the end okay 84
dispatch all right for those squads I
was just talk to my employee the
fighting individuals are still here
they're at the walk-in entrance the
deputy then drives toward where the four
individuals are located spotting them
near The Pedestrian gate of the zoo as
they are apparently waiting for a ride
what's
that individual so someone is picking
you guys up where's your ride my ride
she's on the phone you want to talk to
her I don't need to talk to them where's
your okay I just got here why are you
yelling at me I'm trying to help you out
why are you yelling at me EXC I'm sorry
she right in the front of she said
that's where she dropped the she said
right where she dropped the what car
it's a gr car a car oh it's white a
white sedan it's a white Nissan Nissan
Tima okay calm down I'm calm I don't
have to be calm I'm not hurting you okay
so okay I'm not going to talk to you if
you want to do that so it's a white San
coming to pick you guys up no it's a
what is it Nissan
niss Nissan not
trying they're not trying to let us in
she right there she said she yeah I
can't let you in cuz I have the keys
talk she on us you can press that button
right do you hear her do you hear her
you hear her
right you hear her right yeah I hear her
I'm done talking the G and let us no I'm
not going to open the gate cuz the zoo
is closed hold
on is
the S over there okay let me go okay let
me go get the sedan let me go get the
San and I'll be back are they still uh
parked over there near the ENT we yeah
the the green button open the door we
just trying to get to the car and get
out of here we not trying to
the deputy then dispatches on his radio
to help locate their ride four black
females they're waiting for a ride that
supposedly is inside the zoo it's going
to be a gray
sedan oh yeah there's like a white
hoodie
all right if there's a squad that can go
find this possible white or gray
sedan okay so I got another another
Squad they're going to try to find that
sedan bring it over she said she right
in front of the building seconds later a
17-year-old girl whose face has been
blurred out later identified as Envy
Hampton appears to get verb combative
with the deputy if I hop this fence I'm
going be wrong if you hop this fence I'm
going to arrest you you ain't going to
to me you ain't going to do me if I have
to you hear my sister on the phone Wai
on she said she right in front of the
building we just need to walk over there
and get over there to her okay how about
this instead of you guys going all the
way over there cuz it's a long walk and
it's like 40° out we're going to go get
that sedan we'll bring it around you're
not about you're not about to do a
little you don't need to do that but
yeah she don't have no sedan got a
Nissan I said a Nissan Ultima I said
Ultima ultim a Nissan ultim do we F to
hop in your car y'all about to take us
to the car or what yall planning your L
my nephews is in the car i't going to
lie yall not hearing me I don't give
about that b you not hearing me ma'am do
you have an ID or can I get your name
don't nobody got an ID you can ask for
the ID when you get to the car that's a
ground woman appreciate it that's
a don't it's fun if you don't have your
idea that's
fine then nv's sister who was later
identified as Nia dael Willis arrives in
her car to pick the four up hey there
how's it going hello I'm trying to call
yeah they're all right there okay all
right real quick do you have an ID on
you man' was there like a fight so the
reason we're here today is that
apparently there might have been like
some verbal altercation between some
possible friends or family members or
something like that kind that's why
we're here just make sure everything's
okay do you have an idea on you just so
make no I don't I'm her sister and I'm
just trying to get her out of here and I
don't do police so I don't want to be
extra so just no that's fine I get you
I'll get you out of here okay what's uh
what's a good last name for You Ma'am
why do you need my name to come and pick
up my sister I don't understand because
now I'm having interaction with you that
was a possible fight okay but you don't
need my name to come and get my sister
no you don't that's that's no you don't
need my name all I do isage come on man
y'all need to come on cuz I don't got
time for my kids is in the car and I'm
going to get you out of here in a few
minutes all I need is your name and
that's really about it
okay ma'am we're not doing this around
don't no you don't need to follow me
hold on just hold on I am holding on
I've been sitting here for 10 minutes
sitting here looking for them I don't
need I don't need nothing I'm just going
to come out and go around it don't
matter as a deputy continues to try to
get information from Nia she declines as
a deputy persist she gives him a fake
name Tiffany Willis okay Tiffy yep hold
okay you can let me in my car my kids is
in here come on man for real do not
leave 84 copy of plate then tension
grows after the four are let out of the
gate my sister what is youing what is
you taking my place for you don't need
to do none of that I for what because I
have interaction with you I don't have
it I don't have it I don't have
it I just said my name so what's next
okay all I got to get your name make
surean will
Tiff t i s f i n y Willis w i l i what's
your first name I just said Tiffany
Tiffany open what's your middle m m okay
that's it right what she did at Brook
ma'
why you just said you need my name why
do you need all of that I'm mys are in
the car confus why do I need to get my
information you already tell me they had
alation that's fine I understand all
that but I'm trying to get
home and we never had
no talking about everybody was arguing
with is with me right now need to grab
my door I'm not going to pull need to
grab my door we're not leaving right now
my kids are in the car I need to keep
them warm bro come
on
my before everyone leaves I'll talk to
you over there okay how does that sound
my
name all right hold on okay can I close
my door my is in park you see my hands
can I close my door I'm C my kids are in
here can I talk to either you I'm
talking
to I'm trying to get the out of here I
don't do police I just said that okay I
understand it look I'm not I'm not
you're not going to get in trouble okay
that's not where I know I'm not going to
get in trouble I didn't do all right can
ma'am can I just talk to you outside
over there is that okay God now you need
to talk to her like man come on I don't
have time put him in the back bro to
back I got to talk I got to talk to her
now then that's it all
right I just talk to you over there
what's deal okay let's go over there the
deputy then speaks to one of the women
who seemingly is cooperating with the
investigation she tells the officer
about the events that happened prior
that the altercation was really a verbal
fight between each other oh we just
argue we didn't fight we didn't know we
argue okay they told us to leave we left
we went out here sat out here what we
had to do outside of here don't have
nothing to do in here we was not on the
premises no more we sat out there we
waiting for our ride our ride here we
just ready to go and get it over we not
trying to make it know deeper than what
it is we not trying to nothing we didn't
really disturb them cuz when they told
us to leave we genuinely we left okay
and we and we walked over there that's
when all the police start coming we had
already left and we was we was literally
sitting outside we was been sit outside
here the whole time so you guys okay you
guys it was a family verbal altercation
basically that's what it was right yeah
it wasn't it wasn't nothing with no
other people outside of us it was we
wasn't arguing with other people it was
all with within us we had a little AR
little argument within us they told us
that they was closing the inside so sit
outside we set outside after a little
bit outside they said okay to go we sat
outside all right here now we just ready
to go okay all right so the verbal so
just so I understand what was going on
it was just a verbal ucation between I
guess family yeah we didn't didn't
Outsiders we didn't fight it was just
arguing words back and forth and left
when they told us leave okay so was
anyone injured during this is that
ATT extra police over
here see there's a kid in there I'm
going to get you I understand
okay I'm sorry this happened to
you go ahead
bye yeah I'm speaking of them hold
on close the door hold on make sure the
blanket I want to make sure the blanket
doesn't get caught
okay
okay all
right so no one needs medical attention
no okay was anyone physically assaulted
at all no we just AR and then I guess
they was us like they closing up so they
wanted to like wait outside for our ride
and that's what we did and then after a
minute of that they said leave and we
left is that I'm sorry was his sister
I'm everybody's sister I'm everybody's
sister okay so you were just here
picking them up is a what do I look like
being out here with my kids that's dumb
like come on the women then urged the
deputy to let them all leave but then
when more authorities arrive on scene
the tension escalates you don't got to
come over here why
they nobody got the fight never got the
video then cuts to another deputy's body
cam as he responds to the scene shortly
after arriving you can see multiple
deputies trying to get out the driver
and passengers out of the vehicle let go
of
grab please don't touch
me don't touch me I'll get out but don't
touch me get out don't touch me don't
touch no not touch me get not don't tou
I didn't don't
T after deputies pull Envy sister Nia
out of the car that's when the
17-year-old exits the rear driver side
seat and begins swinging at the
deputy then dash cam video shows a
different of the altercation between the
17-year-old and the deputy showing the
deputy repeatedly strike the teen after
he's hit after the struggle both the
teen and her sister Nia were taken into
custody after the incident court records
reveal Envy Hampton faces a felony
charge of battery on a law enforcement
officer and two misdemeanor charges of
resisting and disorderly conduct
meanwhile mv's sister was also charged
in the incident she faces two
misdemeanors of resisting and disorderly
conduct officials with the Milwaukee
County Sheriff's Office says they have
no further comment or reaction to the
incident while it remains under standard
internal use of force review and while
the DA's office reviews the incident for
charging reporting for long crime
Network I'm Elizabeth Milner